jede Person in der Nähe der Grenze wird
als Terrorist angesehen und muss sofort
neutralisiert werden
beim Versuch
die jüdische Grenze zu überqueren sollen
allein im vergangenen Jahr hunderte
äthiopische Männer Frauen und Kinder
umgebracht worden sein
es waren bewaffnete saudischer Soldaten
sie schossen mit Kugeln auf uns
irgendwer in dieser Bundesregierung hat
diesen Einsatz der deutschen Polizisten
zur Ausbildung der Grenze genehmigt und
alle die daran beteiligt waren sind
mitschuldig die die überlebt haben waren
aus und Bürgerkriegsland Jemen
gesundheitlich schwer angeschlagen
wir wollen zurück in unser Land es ist
die Hölle
ihre Reise in der Hoffnung auf ein
besseres Leben in Saudi-Arabien dauert
Wochen unterwegs auf der festlichen
Route über das Horn von Afrika den Golf
von Aden durch den jenen
750.000
äthiopia sollen in Saudi-Arabien leben
und arbeiten die meisten wollen dem
Krieg und dem Hunger in der Heimat
entkommen deshalb machen sich
Zehntausende jedes Jahr auf den
gefährlichen Weg
doch für viele endet dieser Traum hier
[Musik]
hat Granatsplitter abbekommen
in beiden Beinen
in Arm und Bein
Ghanas Bein wurde von einer Granate
zerfetzt
es waren bewaffnete saudische Soldaten
sie schossen mit Kugeln auf uns es war
in einem Tal dann sind wir in dieses
jemenitische Krankenhaus hier sagen sie
ich werde nie wieder laufen können
seit vier Tagen liegt in diesem
Krankenhaus in der Nähe der geminitisch
saudischen Grenze mindestens 20
Patienten sein ist monatlich die hier
mit schwersten Verletzungen behandelt
würden bestätigt der Oberarzt
die Verletzungen zeigen die Menschen
wurden angegriffen ohne Abstand es sind
direkte Schüsse mit leichten und
schweren Waffen und sie greifen sogar
Frauen Kinder und alte Menschen an
ausnahmslos alle äthiopischen Patienten
hier berichten von saudischen Grenzen
die sie mit unfassbarer Grausamkeit
attackiert hätten
wir wollten durch die Grenze aber sie
benutzten Granatwerfer
jeden Tag sterben Menschen wegen
Granatwerfern und Kugeln jeden Tag jeden
Tag tote das ist ein Riesenproblem warum
schießen Sie auf uns warum stecken sie
uns nicht einfach ins Gefängnis
Zwerge
frischen Grenze soll es seit Jahren
systematisch zu schweren
Menschenrechtsverletzungen durch
saudische Grenzen kommen zu diesem
Schluss kommt ein Bericht von Human
white Swatch die saudische Regierung
aber dementiert das sie sagen es seien
militante Gruppen im Grenzgebiet die auf
die äthiopia schießen würden
eine Lüge behauptet Rabi alnesi er habe
bis Anfang des Jahres für den saudischen
Geheimdienst gearbeitet sei auch an der
Grenze im Einsatz gewesen dort gelte ein
spezieller Befehl von ganz oben
im Jahr 2020 kam ein Tötungsbefehl von
Prinz Mohammed bin Salman persönlich der
Befehl besagt jeden Menschen zu töten
der in die Nähe der saudischen Grenze
kommt dieser Befehl differenziert nicht
zwischen Männern Frauen und Kindern jede
Person in der Nähe der Grenze wird als
Terrorist angesehen und muss sofort
neutralisiert werden
[Musik]
hat der Mann zum ZDF-Interview
eingewilligt er betont auch die
Mitschuld der deutschen Regierung denn
Bundespolizisten sollen mit
Unterbrechungen seit 2009 auch saudische
Grenze ausbilden
ich hoffe die deutsche Regierung stoppt
das Training nun für immer denn die
saudische Regierung tötet bis heute
äthiopische Migranten an der Grenze
überprüfen können wir nicht was er sagt
aber wir wollen mehr über den Vorwurf
erfahren dass Deutschland eine Mitschuld
tragen Rückblick
2008 bekommt der europäische
Rüstungskonzern EADS heute Airbus den
Zuschlag die Grenze Saudi-Arabiens mit
hochspezialisierter
Überwachungstechnologie auszurüsten seit
2009 sollen Bundespolizisten vor Ort im
Einsatz sein der ehemalige
Bundestagsabgeordnete der Linken Jan van
Aken hat 2011 die Bundespolizisten in
Saudi-Arabien besucht er erinnert sich
Polizei geschossen oder war das wir
hatten damals natürlich eher die
Befürchtung deutsche Polizisten bilden
saudische Polizisten aus die dann
foltern und sonst was machen und da
wurde immer gesagt nein wir werden
ausschließlich Grenzsoldaten aus auf
einer regierungspressekonferenz Ende
August will sich die Sprecherin des
Bundesinnenministeriums daran nicht
erinnern
Trainingsmaßnahmen speziell für den
Saudi arabischen Grenzschutz finden
nicht statt und das haben zu keinem
Zeitpunkt Ausbildung oder Trainings der
Bundespolizei für den saudi-arabischen
Grenzschutz im Grenzgebiet zwischen
Saudi Arabien und jenen stattgefunden
mitgenommen
der 2011 vor Ort war
irgendwer in dieser Bundesregierung hat
diesen Einsatz der deutschen Polizisten
zur Ausbildung der Grenze genehmigt und
alle die daran beteiligt waren sind mit
schuldig an all den Verbrechen die jetzt
in dieser Grenze dort begangen werden
mit Schuld die Bundesregierung fordert
nun Aufklärung
unterdessen auf diesem jemenitischen
Friedhof unweit der saudischen Grenze
wir finden eine Grabstelle für
äthiopische Migranten datiert auf Ende
August 2023
Verabredung mit dem örtlichen
Totengräber rrzählt regelmäßig Kim neue
tote es seien Menschen die hier nicht
einheimisch wären sie kommen von der
Grenze warum sind sie gestorben
saudische Grenze haben sie umgebracht
wann kamen die letzten Leichen gestern
und das gehe so seit zehn Jahren es
nehme einfach kein Ende in diesen Tagen
sollen wieder neue tote kommen weitere
Männer Frauen und Kinder aus Äthiopien
und was geschieht mit denen die überlebt
haben wir fahren Richtung Süden 600
Kilometer durch ein Land im Bürgerkrieg
nach Aden am Meer hier haben die aus die
es nicht über die Grenze geschafft haben
am Körper tragen Sie die Narben der
misslungenen Flucht und die Erinnerung
an eine wie sie schildern unmenschliche
Behandlung durch die Saudis
sie haben uns verhaftet wir mussten uns
ausziehen und dann sollten wir uns nackt
für 24 Stunden in die Sonne legen sogar
Frauen mussten das tun
[Musik]
auch sein Leben traumatisiert sein von
dem Versuch die Grenze nach
Saudi-Arabien zu überqueren
du steigst über Leichen überall wo du
hingehst nur Leichen es gibt dort keinen
Ort ohne menschliche Überreste
ich will nie wieder zurück nach
Saudi-Arabien ich werde in mein Land
zurückkehren dort hart arbeiten und dort
reich werden das will ich aber zurück
nach Saudi-Arabien niemals dort wartet
der Tod auf dich sie schießen mit
schwere Artillerie auf jeden einzelnen
seit fünf Monaten wartet Karla auf eine
Chance rauszukommen aus dem Jemen
eigentlich sollten Hilfsorganisationen
Flüge für die Männer organisieren doch
von den Äthiopien hören wir dass die
angeblich umgerechnet 1500 € pro Person
kosten so bleibe ihnen nichts als warten
wir sitzen nur rum und hungern wir
wollen zurück in unser Land aber es gibt
keine Flüge es ist die Hölle
[Musik]
haben zum spontan Protest gerufen sie
wollen auf ihren not aufmerksam machen
sie fordern medizinische Versorgung und
den Rücktransport in ihrer Heimat
sind ich werde nie wieder versuchen nach
Saudi-Arabien zu kommen
wir haben alles verloren mir ist
zumindest das Leben geblieben
[Musik]
wir sagen Stopp zum Migration lasst es
gibt keine Lösung es macht keinen Sinn
es sollen zehntausende sein die nun
verletzt und ausgezehrt festsitzen in
einem Land in dem seit Jahren ein
schwerer bürgerkriegt
ausnahmslos alle hier bereuen ihre
Flucht aus Äthiopien sagen sie die Hölle
sei das was von ihrem Leben geblieben
ist und trotzdem seien sie dankbar dass
sie überlebt haben